father i want to address some of the
criticism by skeptics and we're going to
go through a few one i've heard is that
these individuals are not speaking in
tongues
they will say oh you know these we've
had these recordings analyzed and
linguists have looked at them and it's
actually just a bunch of babel
your response
so there's a difference between speaking
in tongues
which is called glossolalia it's a gift
of the holy spirit
and then people that are possessed who
are speaking the language
so speaking of language would be a
defined language one that we know
even if it's one that's falled out of
practical use
ancient greek latin for example
you know want to speak in aramaic
but again it would be a language that
would be identifiable
at some point in human history but you
would have verification that that was in
fact a language being spoken and not
babble made to sound like a language and
i wouldn't just require just that one
right proof if you will or you know
symptom whatever it might be so i would
still look for other things for others
but that but but on that point you you
feel comfortable saying that it's not
just babel that you've witnessed and
that's the notion of an angelic nature
so why can
a demon speak a language that the person
as an individual doesn't know
and it goes back to saint thomas aquinas
who said that when god created the
angelic world he gave them infused
knowledge
they didn't have to learn anything they
was like downloaded
right so
and they still maintain that attribute
even after the fall
when it comes to the contorted body
postures the twisting um
skeptics will say it's just imitation
they're faking it they're imitating
they're role playing
what have you seen that you would be
able to say no that's not imitation
decisively
yeah bodily distortions would be
things like the arch in the back or the
body moving in positions that are really
not possible for the human person and
again this would be an individual that i
would have have known fairly well
going through the process of
interviewing them getting to know more
about them so it isn't like they walk in
the door and i begin an exorcism so i
will know things about them ahead of
time that goes back to the same way with
the use of language i'm going to know
whether or not they know how to speak
you know
ancient latin for example but like
bodily contortions
can it be something as extreme as like
head spinning completely 360 degrees
around in other words something like
that you couldn't as a human do that and
survive i couldn't make that happen is
it that extreme it is because here's a
good example
the doubters might really like this one
too but during an exorcism i saw
when the demon manifested the person's
jaw dropped and moved off to the side
all the way down off to the site in a
way that would not be humanly possible
that's not possible for a human to do
that
wow do you have any other examples of
things that you've seen
in the room that that
to skeptics
would be beyond
capacity for a mentally ill person for
example so that there would be no
confusion anything else other than you
mentioned the levitating obviously
anything else that you would want to
share that you've witnessed i've
witnessed when people manifest they've
dropped to the floor and began to
slither like a snake for example that
would be another one
but again all of these
contortions if you will are just really
meant
to
distort the human body and the human
person created in the image and likeness
of god have you seen any skin changes
like i had remembered watching a film
where they were talking about skin
eruptions manifesting or bizarre things
like the letters manifest have you have
you seen things manifest on a body that
you know couldn't happen
just from life you know in that moment
yeah when demons manifest usually the
person's complexion
changes how so
you know they're caucasian you know
you'll see they become grayish in tone
okay because again it's really meant
to present the human person as an animal
if you think about the story of creation
in the book of genesis on the sixth day
of creation what did god create he
created animals and humans what
separates humans from animals
it's our capacity
to live for the the sabbath the next day
the lord's day to honor and glorify god
and so the demons in rejecting god the
reason they are animalistic in nature is
there is no recognition of god if you
like the short clip you can catch
another one here or you can catch the
full episode right here
[Music]